polls are now open in Georgia for the
United States House special election
Democrat John Asaf and Republican karen
handel are fighting to fill the seat
left empty by Tom Price he became
Secretary of Health and Human Services
the runoff race in Georgia's solidly
Republican six district is widely seen
as a referendum on President Trump mark
Strassmann is just outside Atlanta in
Marietta Georgia mark good morning
good morning in a typical election year
Democrat John Asaf might expect to get
clobbered this is a Republican district
he's never run for office before he
doesn't even live in this district but
we live in an unusual times politically
john ASSA thank you a 30-year old rookie
candidate thanks for them knows these
volunteers will turn out for him today
but to turn this red district blue the
former congressional aide needs to poach
as many unhappy Republican voters as he
can what will encourage last-minute
voters to break one way the other it's a
neck-and-neck race it's going to all
going to come down to turnout Republican
karen handel knows that too I think
probably about half the vote is taking
place in the early vote so the second
half is going to be on election day so
we just need all of our voters to come
out and make sure they cast their
ballots as the Republican Georgia's
former Secretary of State could expect
to be the favorite but anti-trump
sentiment has helped fuel the most
expensive congressional race in history
karen handel has used her political
power to serve herself almost 50 million
dollars has been spent in the race so
far much of that on TV ads food gets
John Ross on all of this I think comes
down to two words Donald Trump this
district has become a real referendum on
President Trump and his agenda back in
April the president showed support for
handle at an NRA rally get out and vote
you know she's running against someone
who's going to raise your taxes to the
sky he reinforced that message this
morning tweeting Democrat John Asaf who
wants to raise your taxes to the highest
level and as week on crime and security
doesn't even live in District
if this congressional seat goes Democrat
it would go Democrat for the first time
since 1978 when Georgian Jimmy Carter
was president Jeff mark thank you very
much